brendan frazier is making a comeback in
a remarkable way
it's exciting
brendan is transforming into a 600 pound
man and a first look at the upcoming
film the well where he stars alongside
stranger things sadie sink
on tuesday production company a24
released the first photo of the 53 year
old actor in the role of a reclusive
writing instructor who was struggling to
reconnect with his teenage daughter
and in an interview with unilad last
year he teased what fans can expect from
the film
saying quote is gonna be like something
you haven't seen before that's really
all i can tell you the wardrobe and
costume was extensive seamless
cumbersome the well is set to debut at
the 2022 venice film festival later this
year
the movie marks the mummy actor's first
leading role since the 2013 film
breakout plus he's also part of martin
scorsese's upcoming film killers of the
flower moon all this good news for
brendan is something fans on tiktok are
calling a renaissance
and last year during a meet and greet
brendan geeked out over his chance to
work with heavyweights like scorsese
robert de niro and leonardo dicaprio the
dad of three also got vulnerable and
revealed he's a bit nervous he might be
sick a little anxious
oh no i mean it's gonna be fun that's
when a fan reassured him that the
internet is always cheering him on and
will always have his back
you've got this you've got this just
just know that the internet is so behind
you we're so supportive there are so
many people out there who love you and
we're rooting for you and we can't wait
to see what you do next
shucks man
the well and killers of the moon is not
all brendan has coming down the pipeline
we'll see him next playing the villain
in dc's batgirl
speaking of girl last year et spoke with
leslie grace and she teased what fans
can expect from her take on the
superhero i'm learning from other
friends of mine it's like you you put a
little bit of yourself into each each
character and uh in the bit of research
that i've that i've been doing leading
into pre-production i've learned a lot
of things about barbara that are very in
line with with me and so i'm excited i
mean she's
she's someone who's been you know
underestimated by her own even her own
dad and like just you know being a the
youngest kid sometimes you're insulated
from all of the like tough stuff of life
and she's so eager to um
to just prove to herself and to
everybody else that she there's some
things that she can handle um and so
this journey is definitely going to show
me a lot of that that i feel like i'm on
an endless journey of like proving to
myself what i what barriers i can break
what limits i can i can break for myself
and i'm excited to put a little bit of
that eagerness and just drive and like
almost a bit of stubbornness into
into barbara's character